WHEN IT COMES TO HAVING A
CUSHION, THAT IS NOT GOOD FOR
THE CYCLE.
>>> AND IT COULD BE THE MOST
CONSEQUENTIAL RACE OF THE YEAR.
THAT COULD DETERMINE WHO
CONTROLS THE SENATE.
THAT'S WHY IT'S SO CRUCIAL.
JOHN FETTERMAN HAS BEEN OFF THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL FOR MONTHS DUE TO
THE SUDDEN STROKE HE HAD.
AND THE REPUBLICAN, DR. OZ, IS
FACING QUESTIONS ABOUT WHY HE'S
NOT IN THE STATE, HE'S
APPARENTLY BEEN IN NEW JERSEY
AND NOT CAPITALIZING ON HIS
OPPONENT'S ABSENCE ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL IN PENNSYLVANIA.
JEFF ZELENY IS "OUTFRONT"
TONIGHT IN PITTSBURGH.
>> Reporter: IT'S BEEN TWO
MONTHS SINCE JOHN FETTERMAN HIT
THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
A RACE WITH MEHMET OZ THAT COULD
DETERMINE THE BALANCE OF POWER
IN THE SENATE.
FETTERMAN IS STILL SLOWLY
EMERGING FROM A NEAR DEADLY S
SETBACK, A STROKE AND HEART
CONDITION THAT SENT HIM TO THE
HOSPITAL.
FOUR DAYS LATER, HE SWEPT TO AN
EASY DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY VICTORY.
BUT EVER SENSE, HE'S BEEN
SIDELINED AND FIGHTING TO
RECOVER.
A SURPRISE VISIT WITH DEMOCRATIC
VOLUNTEERS LAST WEEKEND, SEEP
HERE IN THIS EDITED CAMPAIGN
VIDEO, SHOWS THE PROMISE OF HIS
RETURN AND THE SERIOUS STEPS
STILL AHEAD IN HIS
REHABILITATION.
>> WE WILL BE BACK ON THE TRAIL
SOON!
WE'RE ALMOST AT 100%.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Reporter: HIS SPEECH IS
HALTING, YET STRONGER, AIDES
SAY, THAN A MONTH AGO.
>> IT WAS ALMOST THE END OF MY
LIFE, AND IT'S CHANGED MY LIFE
SINCE THEN.
>> Reporter: HIS SURPRISE
APPEARANCE AT THE PITTSBURGH
CAMPAIGN OFFICE BROUGHT A SMILE
AND SENSE OF RELIEF TO GLADYS.
>> IT WAS GREAT TO SEE HIM.
HE WAS, YOU KNOW, HE JUST LOOKED
SO VIBRANT, LIKE HE REALLY CAME
THROUGH ALL OF THOSE DIFFICULT
HEALTH PROBLEMS.
>> HAVE YOU BEEN WONDERING HOW
HE'S BEEN DOING?
>> YES, I HAVE.
>> Reporter: WHILE OZ IS SEEKING
TO CAPITALIZE AS HIS CELEBRITY
AS A TV DOCTOR, SOME REPUBLICANS
WONDER IF HE'S TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF FETTERMAN'S ABSENCE.
>> PENNSYLVANIA IS OUR HOME.
AND IT'S WORTH FIGHTING FOR.
>> Reporter: FROM AFAR,
FETTERMAN IS BADGERING OZ FOR
MOVING TO PENNSYLVANIA.
AFTER LIVING IN NEW JERSEY FOR
MORE THAN THREE DECADES.
FLYING A WELCOME HOME BANNER
OVER THE JERSEY SHORE.
>> I'M HERE TO SPEAK TRUTH TO
TOWER.
R
>> Reporter: AND BLAST ED OOZE
FOR FILMING AN AD FROM HIS
JERSEY MANSION.
>> THE LAST TIME FETTERMAN
APPEARED AT A CAMPAIGN EVENT WAS
THEY 12.
HIS WIFE SAID SHE NOTICED
SOMETHING WAS WRONG THE NEXT
MORNING.
>> CAME BACK TO THE CAR, HE WAS
TALKING TO ME, AND FOR ONE
SECOND, HIS MOUTH MOVED IN AN
UNNATURAL WAY.
IMMEDIATELY, I RUSHED HIM TO THE
HOSPITAL.
>> Reporter: HE LEFT THE
HOSPITAL NINE DAYS LATER WITH A
DEFIBRILLATOR IMPLANTED IN HIS
CHEST, TO RECOVER JUST OUTSIDE
OF PITTSBURGH.
SUMMER LEE, WHO IS RUNNING FOR
CONGRESS, SAID SHE OFTEN SEES
FETTERMAN OUT WALKING AS HE
CONTINUES TO RECOVER.
>> OBVIOUSLY, THE SOONER WE CAN
GET HIM BACK ON THE TRAIL THE
BETTER.
IF WE CAN GET HIM BACK FOR THE
LONG HAUL, YOU KNOW, AFTER LABOR
DAY, I THINK HE'S GOING TO BE IN
GOOD SHAPE.
WE ARE GOING TO BE BETTER FOR
THAT.
>> JEFF, LOOK, MONTHS OFF THE
TRAIL.
THIS RACE IS SO CRUCIAL.
YOU KNOW, YOU'VE GOT A RIVAL WHO
DOESN'T SPEND MUCH TIME IN THE
STATE.
HOW IS THIS PLAYING OUT WITH
VOTERS?
ARE THE VOTERS THAT YOU SPOKE TO
WORRIED ABOUT FETTERMAN'S
HEALTH, HIS ABILITY TO DO THE
JOB?
>> Reporter: LOOK, ERIN,
FETTERMAN HAS BEEN OUT OF SIGHT
BUT NOT OUT OF MIND.
USUALLY SEVERAL TIMES A DAY,
SOMETIMES HOUR BY HOUR, HE'S
ENGAGED ON SOCIAL MEDIA,
RESPONDING TO THE ISSUES OF THE
DAY ON TWITTER, GOING AFTER OZ
ON TWITTER, AS WELL.
BUT THE VOTERS WE TALKED TO HAVE
BEEN WONDERING WHETHER HE IS.
HAVE BEEN WONDERING HOW HIS
HEALTH IS.
IT'S ALL OUT OF CONCERN, OF
COURSE.
BUT THERE WAS A DEEP SENSE OF
RELIEF WHEN HIS CAMPAIGN POSTED
THAT VIDEO ON SATURDAY OF HIM
WALKING AND SPEAKING.
THE QUESTION, OF COURSE, WILL HE
BE READY FOR DEBATES WITH OZ IN
THE FALL?
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT AUGUST 15,
THE LAST DAY TO CHANGE HIS NAME